une première visite du chantier de ce
qui deviendra la future maison de
radio-canada
ici on est dans l'atrium c'est l'espace
public c'est l'espace que pourront
visiter les gens qui se rendent à radio
canada pour assister à une émission ou à
un événement essentiellement c'est le
grand studio vous donnez une des
présentement au 142 lorsqu'on fait des
soupçons comme tout le monde en parle où
n'importe quelle émission de variétés ce
que vous voyez là c'est l'atrium
l'endroit public
ici on se transporte dans les studios de
radio d'où vont parvenir les émissions
de radio canada
un départ est acté un beau coup de
vitrages beaucoup de lumière dont on
peut très bien imaginer l'équipe du
matin qu' un peu voir temps réel la
météo la circulation sur le pont
l'espace on se trouve présentement c'est
le futur plateau du téléjournal 18 ans
avec patrice fois à 22 ans avec céline
galipeau et il ya encore cette vue vers
l'atrium donc les gens qui rentrent le
public et en menant radio canada on
pourra en voir un peu ce qui se passe
sur nos plateaux de télévision radio
canada sera locataire de l'immeuble
on s'est engagé sur un bail de 30 ans et
le coût de notre voyez votre de 20
millions par un nuit chic pour les 30
prochaines semaines
donc c'est sensiblement le même prix que
radio-canada pour gérer la toiture
exactement mais un prix fixe pour les
prendre prochainement
le vice président principal ajoute que
la facture pour rénover l'actuel maison
du boulevard rené lévesque était trop
élevé ça nous aurait coûté juste pour
les mettre à jour parce qu relance de
l'amiante fait le changement des
fenêtres elle a changé la plomberie on
en avait pour 162 6 millions us pour mai
la tour au goût du jour et on n'avait
aucun investissement technologies pour
se montrer comme radio canada doit
encore négocier avec les fournisseurs
le coût total de ce déménagement ne sera
annoncé qu'une fois tous terminés on est
sur la terrasse de la future maison de
radio-canada vous allez sûrement avoir
plusieurs directe d'un journaliste à
partir d'ici radio canada va prendre
possession de sa future maison au début
de l'année 2020 mais l'inauguration
officielle sera plutôt à l'automne 2020
ici vincent maisonneuve radio-canada
mourir